[موسيقى]
نزل قرار طالبان بمنع الفتيات من التعليم
الجامعي نزول الصاعقه على الفتيات والنساء
في مختلف عن حياه افغانستان القرار جاء
ضمن سلسله من القرارات التي اتخذتها
الحركه منذ عودتها الى الحكم في اغسطس
بالعام الماضي ضد تعليم المراه وعملها
بداتها بمنع تدريس البنات في المدارس
المتوسطه والثانويه بعده قامت بطرد
الافغانيات العاملات في الوظيفه العامه ثم
حضرت ارتياد النساء المتنزهات العامه
والفضاءات الرياضيه كما الغت وزاره شؤون
المراه واستبدلتها بشرطه الاخلاق وكان اخر
هذه القرارات منع المراه من العمل لدى
المنظمات المحليه والاجنبيه
قراراته حكومه الطالبان هذه وجوبها
باستنكار وتمديد من المجتمع الدولي فما هي
الدوافع وراء تراجع الحركه عن تعهداتها
باحترام حقوق المراه الافغانيه وهل ستنجح
الضغوط الدوليه والداخليه في ثني الحركه
عن قراراتها و تجبرها على تخفيف قيودها
على النساء والفتيات اهلا بكم في هذه
الحلقه من سيناريوهات
[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم
2021 باحترامي حقوق المراه الافغانيه وما
ابدته من مؤشرات طمانت لان قراراتها
الاخيره هذه اعتبرت نكسه كبيره وتراجع عن
تلك التعبدات عن قرارات حكومه طالبان بمنع
الفتيات من التعليم الجامعي والعمل لدى
المنظمات المحليه والاجنبيه وما اثرته من
تداعيات داخليه
يسعدنا ان يكون معنا في هذه الحلقه هنا في
الاستديو الدكتور سلطان بركات الاستاذ في
كليه السياسات العامه في جامعه محمد بن
خليفه
الوزير السابقه للسياسات والتخطيط في
وزاره شؤون المراه الافغانيه ومن كابل
المحلل السياسي نصرت عقبه فاهلا بهم جميعا
مع تصاعدي حده الانتقادات لقرارات حركه
طالبان المقيده لحريه المراه يزداد الغموض
بشان مستقبل العمل الانساني الدولي في
افغانستان ومصير الطلبات الطالبات
والموظفات في المؤسسات التعليميه
والجماعيه
[موسيقى]
للحصول على الاعانات الدوليه ما لم يتغير
قرار حكومه طالبان المثير للجدل في هذا
البلد يحتاج اكثر من 28 مليون شخص
للمساعدات للبقاء على قيد الحياه لكن
منظمات الاغاثه الدوليه تنظر بوقف نشاطها
ما لم تتراجع طالبان عن قرار منع عمل
الافغانيات ضمن الفرق الاغاثيه سبع من هذه
المنظمات لم تنتظر وعلقت بالفعل نشاطها في
افغانستان
قد تتوسع لتشمل منظمات دوليه اخرى وزيره
التنميه الالمانيه التي تتولى بلادها
رئاسه مجموعه الدول الصناعيه السبع اعلنت
تاييدها وقف الدعم المقدم في اطار الصندوق
الائتماني لاعاده اعمار افغانستان وقالت
انها تعتزم الدعوه الى اجتماع للاطراف
الفاعله في هذا الصندوق بالتعاون مع البنك
الدولي للنظر في اقرار ذلك
يمول ذلكم الصندوق مهمات تغطي نظام الصحه
والتعليم في افغانستان ثم ان المنظمات غير
الحكوميه ايضا مصدر اساسي للوظائف لعشرات
الالاف من الافغان في ظل انهيار الاقتصاد
المحلي
ليس هذا فحسب هناك جبهه اخرى تصارع
الافغانيات للخلاص منها فقرروا منعهن من
التعليم الجامعي بسبب الحجاب مشكله اخرى
هنا تجرات مجموعه صغيره
في تحدي لحكومه طالبان
وامام جامعه كابولا تقف هنا مروه ذات 18
عاما بمفردها حامله اللافته كتبت عليها
كلمه اقرا وتنجدد بحرمانها ومسيلاتها من
الالتحاق بالجامعه
احتجاجات النساء في افغانستان نادره اذ
تجابهها حركه طالبان بالقوه وسبق ان
اعتقلت ناشطات افغانيات في بدايه السنه
فقبل قرارين منع التعليم ومنع العمل سبقت
اجراءات اخرى مقيده لحريه النساء شملت
استبعادهن من معظم الوظائف العامه واعطاء
العاملات منهن اجورا زهيده ومنعهن من
السفر دون محرم ومن ارتياد المتنزهات
والحدائق والمسابح العامه
قراراتها بان الشرف الافغاني لا يسمح بمنح
كل تلك الحريات للمراه فان الضغوط الدوليه
تنظر بمصير غير ساهر للافغان فما زالت
حكومه طالبان تبحث عن الاعتراف الدولي وما
زالت افغانستان تنتظر رفع العقوبات التي
يرزح تحتها اقتصادها
الصراعات والسياسيه في افغانستان
والموروثات والثقافيه شكلت حاله سلبيه على
بيئه التعليم في افغانستان الارقام
التاليه توضح مدى ذلك التاثير
لا يتجاوز معدل التحاق الاناث بالتعليم
العالي في افغانستان واحدا في المئه من
الفئه العمريه المعنيه بالالتحاق بالجامعه
وفقا لتقارير الامم المتحده المعنيه وهي
ادنى نسبه بين جميع البلدان ياتي ذلك في
ظل وجود اربعين جامعه حكوميه 140 جامعه
خاصه لا تزالوا معظم مدارس البنات
الثانويه في افغانستان والتي يبلغ عدده
1880 مدرسه مغلقه قبل وصول طالبان لسلطه
عام
1996 كانت نسبه المعلمين من النساء جامعه
قابل تصل 60% وما يقرب من نصف الطلاب من
الاناث بالاضافه الى هذا شكله النساء نحو
70% من معلمي المدارس و50% من موظفي
الحكومه المدنيين واربعين في المئه من
الاطباء
دكتور سلطان بركات اهلا وسهلا بك دكتور
بركات انت من كنت من بين الذين كانوا على
مقربه من المحادثات الامريكيه الافغانيه
هنا في الدوحه وكنت على تواصل مع هذه
الدوائر ما الذي جعل حركه طالبان تتراجع
عن تعهداتها
للمجتمع الدولي بخصوص بحقوق المراه
انا اعتقد اللي حصل هو مواجهتهم للواقع في
افغانستان انا لا اؤمن في نظريه انه كان
في عندهم حاولوا يبيعوا نظره معينه وبعدين
تراجعوا عنها حركه كامله ااه الحقيقه انه
لما دخلوا الى البلد في حكومه اول صدمه هي
صدمه الانتقال الحركه قتاليه الى دوله ولا
الان لم يتعامل مع هذه الانتقال بشكل صحيح
لا زال الامير موجود في كندهار وليست
العاصمه العاصمه في كابول تقريبا يعني
تدار الدوله من قبل الحكم الحكومه اللي هي
حكومه الاعمال المؤقته اللي تم انشاءها
وسميت بحكومه مؤقته يعني فتح الباب لمجال
انه يتم تعديل وهمم اشتراك الاخرين وعندك
الحكومه في كنداري اللي هو الامير وبعد
الاشخاص اللي حوله وهذه تحكم بشكل كامل
منطقه كندا هذه البشتونيه القبليه
وتؤثر قرارات ايضا على الوضع فيها
افغانستان بشكل عام
فالواقع اللي وصلوله هو اول شيء انقطاع
التعليمي اللي ذكر الان في التقرير كان
تقريبا يعتمد 60 الى 70 في بعض المناطق
80% عن المساعدات الخارجيه مساعدات هذه
انتهت
العالم جاءوا وقال ان احنا نعطي فقط
مساعدات انسانيه همم غذاء اساسيه ولن ندخل
في اي مساعدات من خلال الدوله لانه هاي
الدوله الان غير معترفه فيها فهذا اول
واقع اللي هو لا يوجد موارد اصلا
لفتح المدارس بالاعداد اللي يحتاجها الشعب
في افغانستان يعني هل يمكن اعتباره نوع من
لفت انتباه او محاوله اثاره مشكل حتى
يلتفت اليها المجتمع الدولي في منه الكلام
انه هو ممكن يعتبر ورق الضغط اخيره في
يدهم العالم لانهم علاقاتهم الدوليه
محدوده الان اا فهذا الموضوع يهتم فيه
المجتمع الدولي في كل وقت واخر يحاول انه
يحركوا هذا الكارت حتى يصير فيه نوع من
الاهتمام في هذا نسال
همم حسنه جليل
كيف نظرت الى الى تراجع الحركه
بتطمنات البعض لم يصدقها منذ البدايه
والبعض الان فوجئ انها تراجعت عنها
شكرا
لا اعتقد بالنسبه للمجتمع الدولي بالنسبه
للمجتمع الدولي ربما كان الامر مفاجئا لكن
لا اعتقد ان الامر كان مفاجئا بالنسبه لاي
افغاني اتذكر عندما كانت الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه تتفاوض مع الطالبان فان المراه
الافغانيه كانت خالقه بشكل كبير جدا
الوعود التي تقدمت بها طالبان وعندما تقلد
الطالبان السلطه كنت اعتقد ان المراه
الافغانيه بما في ذلك انا كنا ننتظر
بهذه السقوط بهذه المراسيل بالان يتم
اصدارها كنا ننتظر من سيكون محتوى هذه
المراسيم الامر لم يكون واضحا
بشان القيود المتزايده القيود المتزايده
التي
اذا كانت هناك همم امراه
عاشت تحت هذه السياسات التي كانت تنتهيجها
طالبا هم يفهمون هذا الامر هو لدينا
القرارات التي تم اتخاذها بشان المؤسسات
التعليميه اخر قرار كان يخص الجامعات حضر
الفتيات من دخول التعليم الجامعي اذا
طالبان تتحدث عن غياب المساعدات الدوليه
ومساعدات المجتمع الدولي تحدث كذلك عن
التعليم المختلطه وتحدث عن عدم قدرتهم عن
اداره
المساكن الفتيات وسكن الفتيات بالنسبه
للفتيات اللواتي ياتينا من ولايات بعيده
وكذلك الحديث عن القيم والتقاليد
الاسلاميه والافغانيه اذا لم تكن هذه فقط
التمرينات التي قدمتها وانما كان هناك
امور اخرى ولكن اذا اه كنت لاعبر عن الامر
بطريقه اخرى الامر لم يكن صادما بنسبه
للمراه الافغانيه وهذا الامر تحدثنا عنه
وبصوت مرتفع وبينناه بشكل واضح عندما كانت
الولايات المتحده تتفاوض مع افغانستان
نفس السيد نصره عقبه في كابل هل هناك
انطباع بان الحركه مستت في مصداقيتها التي
ظنها البعض فيها بمعنى انها تعهدت ثم نثت
تعهداتها بشكل واضح بل وسارخ ايضا
ثانكيو
شديد في افغانستان
دوليه اخرى بانهن لم لن يمنعوا المراه من
التعليم والعمل على اساس القوانين
الاسلاميه
والثقافه
افغانيه اذا راينا همم
قرارات
بمنع التعليم
ومنع المراه من العمل في المنظمات غير
الحكوميه والان نرى في وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي لقاشا حقيقيا حول
معاه المحليه الافغانيه في نقاشها حول
تبادل الاراء حول ممثلين
اماره افغانستان اسلاميه
وفي ذلك الوقت
كانت حركه وعدت الشعب الافغاني لماذا
تغيرون
ولا تفونا بوعودكم
وهناك انتقادات
من جانب العديد من المعلقين
والمشاركين لذلك ما نراه الان وهذه اجواء
في وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي في همم وكذلك
الحياه الحقيقيه واليوميه في كل مكان في
افغانستان
هو محلل سياسي تخيل ان لم نستطيع ونحن نعد
هذا البرنامج
استطع لم نفلح في العثور على اي شخص من
طالبان او من داخل افغانستان مستعد للدفاع
عن وجهه النظر همم
اطالبانيه او الدفاع عن هذا القرار هذا في
حد ذاته مؤشر معبر لا داخل الحركه ولا
داخل المجتمع هناك من هو مستعد للدفاع هذا
كيف يمكن ان يقرا
هو همم قراءه واقعيه لان هو 90% واكثر من
قيادات الحركه ضد هذا القرار لانه لا قرار
لا يتماشها حتى على ايديولوجيه لا يتماشى
مع الدين الاسلامي لا يتماش مع تنميه
الدوله
ما قيل همم وما يتداول انه هو وزير
التعليم العالي مثلا هذا القرار كان نتيجه
حديث بينه وبين الامير
وحتى في في صيغه القرار هو ذكر اجتماع
لمجلس الوزراء وفي الحقيقه هذا الاجتماع
لم يحصل لم يكن هناك اجتماع مجلس الوزراء
ادى الى هذا القرار فهذا عملوا المشكله
الحقيقيه داخل الحركه وهو يمثل انه في
هناك نوع من التنافس همم على الاراء وعلى
الافكار داخل القياده الطالب يعني من
يتحدث
متشدد وشك همم يعني عملي او واقعي هذا
الكلام نعم موجود شغل متشد متشدد يمكن عاش
معظم حياته في الخنادق في القتال يرى
المستقبل من وجهه نظر معينه وشق اكبر
واكثر اللي هو الناس اللي خرجوا وتعاملوا
مع العالم وعندما تختلفوا هذه الاراء كانت
هي اللي في البدايه هي اللي دخلت طالبان
كابول وهي اللي ادت الى التعامل
الشبه جيد اللي همم قاموا فيه من بدايه
الى مارس يعني تقريبا سته اشهر كانت
الامور مبشره وشوي شوي شوي دخلت هذه
العناصر الاخرى في في هذا الخليط وهي
نتيجه ترجع النقطه الاولى هي ضعف في في
الحكم يعني يجب ان يكون هناك طريقه اخرى
لدراسه مثل هذه القرارات نعم يعني دكتور
المجتمع الدولي عندما ندد معروف لكن حتى
دوله مثل قطر التي ساهمت في التعاون مع
طالبان واجلاء الرعايه الاجانب وحتى
محاوله جعلها مقبوله اكثر من المجتمع
الدولي هكذا ساعه الدوحه حتى قطر ندره
بالقرار هي اعربت عن خيبه املها وعن
استغرابها من الحركه من من من هذا القرار
يعني ليس فقط داخل الافغانستان لكن حتى
خارج افغانستان لا احد قابل بذلك صحيح
لانه ما في لا احد يستفيد من هذا القرار
حتى هم نفسهم اعضاء الحركه يفشلوا اذا هذا
القرار فعلا استمر على سبيل المثل هم
يتكلم عن همم اهميه همم
ابعاد الذكور عن الاناث والتفريق في ما
بينهم من من في المدارس في المستشفيات في
المعاملات العامه في الباصات الاخرى كيف
بدك تستطيع انك تعمل هذا الحكي بدون ما
يكون في عندك سيدات دارسيين
بتاعه روانسات ومعلمات الاخ لا يمكن انك
تستمر في هذه الطريقه فهو اصل القرار يعني
غير واقعي وسيؤدي في ال- في النهايه انا
اعتقد الى يعني خلافات لن تحل بشكل جيد
نعم
سيد حسنى جليل
الموقف من تعليم البنات في افغانستان من
قبل حركه الطالبان
وقع بنوع من التدرج اولا التعليم فقط الان
التعليم الابتدائي فقط تعليم الاعدادي
والثانوي منع على الفتيات الجامعات كانت
توجيه باختصاصات دون اختصاصات همم يعني
ابعدهم عن الهندسه عن الاعلام همم عن همم
اختصاصات اخرى همم الان وصلنا الى الملعب
كيف تنظرين الى هذا التدرج في التضييق على
تعليم البنات
لكن عندما يتعلق الامر بما يجري
الاسباب التي جعلتهم يبررون حضرت تعليم
المراه او الفتاه العاديه قالوا ان هناك
بعض التخصصات بداوا بان بعد التخصصات غير
مناسبه بالنسبه للمراه اذا لا اعتقد ان
هذه هي اسباب
يؤمنون بها لانهم ضد التعليم ضد تعليم
المراه
حتى هم منقسمون بداخلهم نعم اتفق معهم
لكن هناك هناك مساله واضحه بالنسبه للجميع
بغض النظر عن من يقوم باصدار القرارات او
المراسيم كل القياده كل الاعضاء الذين
قاموا ببيعه الزعيم هم يطبقونه هذه
السياسات اذا بالنسبه لنا عندما ننظر الى
الصوره الاعم والاكبر فان طالبا لديهم
سياسات معاديه للمراه وهي غير مختلفه عن
مكان عنه الام عليه الامر في التسعينيات
من القرن الماضي وكل هذا الطالبان يطبقون
وينفذون هذه السياسات لا اعتقد ان
المبررات التي قدموها
للناس هي مقنعه حتى بالنسبه لهم هناك بعض
التخصصات التي ربما قد تكون مناسبه للرجل
اكثر من المراه وما الى ذلك لا اعتقد انهم
يؤمنون ويصدقون هذه التبريرات هذه امور
فقط مها للناس بيبسي حتى
ينشغل الناس بهذه التمريرات
كما يبدو ولكن كيف يمكن ان نتوقع جيلا
جديدا في افغانستان
امهاتهم كلهم من الجهله تقريبا يعني اذا
كانت المراه فقط للتعليم الابتدائي بمعنى
تعرف تقرا وتكتب لا غير كيف نتوقع ان يكون
الجيل المقبل في في البلاد
سوق الحظ
الوقايه او منع الناس
من القاده القادمين لدوره ماء لا هو قرار
غير مبرر ومؤسوف وهو مؤسف ايضا
اعتقد انه ينبغي ان يكون حذرين
بالانتباه الى انه لا يمكن ان نحدد
وان نعرف نقدم اي تعريف
لحركه همم طالبان والحكومه الحاليه مثلا
بعضه اصدقائنا
محليه ودوليا يتوقعون ان اماره افغانستان
هي جسمه انه واحد وله عقليه واحده من
الاعلى ومتحده حول افكار معينه لو دخلنا
وت
ودرسنا وحللنا ال- ال- المجموعات المختلفه
او العقليات المختلفه في الحكومه الحاليه
فا نفهم
لاننا نشهد في الوقت الحاضر ان معظم
الحكومه التنفيذيه في كابول غير راضيه
وهمم على لهذا القرار والذين هم قريبون من
المسؤولين زعماء الحكومه ويسمونهم شيوخ او
قاده روحيون ف- همم هم همم متفائلون
ويدعمون هذه الفكره
اذا لا يمكن ان نحدد انه نعرف او نحدد
نقدم تعريفا
واحدا
لوجهه وجهات النظر
والافاق الاستراتيجيه لشؤون الداخليه او
الدوليه من حكومه افغانستان الحاليه لذلك
فهناك فروق فروقات وهناك اختلافات في همم
لدى داخل الحكومه
وهناك اجتماعات تتم حول همم رفع هذه
المحظورات والقيود المفروضه على الفتيات
والنساء وايضا في الحياه الاجتماعيه
وجوانبها الاخرى يمكن ان اقول ان هناك كيف
يقول ذلك همم عقليه موازيه
فيوز اا في وجهات النظر
بما يتعلق بشؤون الحكم في وشؤون الناس اذا
هناك انقسام في الحكومه حتى بين
القاده بعضهم
يدعمونا التعليم وعمل المراه همم وهناك
اخرون هم ضد هذا همم هذا هذه القرارات وهم
الذين يقفون وراء هذه القرارات
ومن هم ضد او مع ويقولون ان هذه همم
قرارات ينبغي ان يتم رفعها
ولدينا معلومات
بان هناك اجتماعات
متكرره في كابول في النظري في كيفيه
اقناعي القاده في كابول وكيف ان ذلك سيكون
له انعكاس سلبي على الناس وعلى راي
المجتمع الدولي في افغانستان وسنخسر الدعم
همم
الشعب هو سيكون هو الخاسر لذلك هناك همم
قلق في همم صفوف الحكومه في كابول همم اذا
معنى ذلك ان امكانيه همم
تبقى وارده سنعود الى هذا الموضوع الى مدى
يمكن فعلا الحركه ان تتراجع ولكن المساله
لا تقف فقط عند التعليم لان هناك ايضا
قرار اخر ضد النساء في افغانستان يتمثل
هذه المره في منع المراه الافغانيه من
العمل في المنظمات الاجنبيه والمحليه وذلك
كما جاء في رساله من وزاره الاقتصاد ارسلت
الى هذه المنظمات وقد هددت هذه الرساله
بالغاء ترخيص اي منظمه لا تلتزموا بالحظر
على وجه السرعه
سبع منظمات اجنبيه اغلقت ابوابها احتجاجا
على القرار الذي ادى الى تقليل نسبه
الموظفين العاملين في هذه المنظمات الى
65%
وتقدر حصه النساء في المنظمات الاجنبيه
والمحليه ب 35
% حسب الزام دول التمويل
وتعملوا في افغانستان منذ نحو 30 عاما
منظمه اجنبيه ومحليه بينها 100 منظمه
محليه
وثلاث وثمانون اجنبيه
ويقدر برنامج الامم المتحده الانمائي
خساره افغانستان نتيجه منع المراه
الافغانيه من العمل بمليار دولار امريكي
كل عام
وتقول المنظمات الدوليه ان اكثر من 80% من
الشعب الافغاني تحت خط الفقر
دكتور بركات بالنسبه لموضوع العمل في
المنظمات المحليه والدوليه القرار هو
حتى اشعار اخر يعني الحظر حتى اشعار اخر
ولكن ما تداعياته بتقديره لان هؤلاء
النسوه لا يعملن في هذه المنظمات بعضهم
يعيل عائلات ب 10 افراد 15 فرد يعني عندما
يعودنا الى بيوتهن هذا تراجع في مداخيل كل
اسره بمعنى مزيد من تفقير الشعب الافغاني
طبعا واشوف في ملاحظه لما ندخل في هذا
الموضوع كل القرارات هاي لا تاتي بمنعه
وانما تعلق ومعلق التعليم الثانوي للبنات
الى
شعارنا التعارف حتى يصير هناك همم يعني
شروط معينه هم وضعها
ثم يعني سيتم النظر في هذا قوم يتحجزون
بقضيه اللباس اللباس الشرعي او غير شرعي
والاختيار
قرارا بصرامه في ما يتعلق باللباس مع انه
اغلبهن ملتزمات بهذا الموضوع
محافظ وهم بيعرفوا هذا الكلام لكن
الفرصه الضائعه ان هم بيعلقوا هذه الامور
ولكن لا يعمل على حلها همم مثلا تعليم
للمراحل الثانويه علق في شهر ثلاثه الماضي
كان المفروض مع بدايه العام الدراسي
الجديد يكون في هناك خطه موجوده واضحه ما
هي الاحتياجات كيف يمكن التعامل مع
المجتمع الدولي الدولي بحل هذه مشاكل لكن
هنا الان لم ياتي اي حال من طرف الحركه
نرجع على موضوع النساء والمؤسسات
الانسانيه
او هم عادا كما شيء لم يمنع من الوظائف
العامه همم الا انه همم في شروط ان كيف
طبيعه اللباس لما تكون في داخله في
الوزاره
همم
في المنظمات طبعا
للعاملات انفسهم ولكن يسيء اكثر
للمستفيدين من المساعدات معظم المستفيدين
من المساعدات هم ارامل همم مسؤولين عن
عائلات كبيره
ومعظمهم من النساء فانت كيف بدك توصل
المساعدات للنساء بدون ما تستخدم النساء
توصل بيوتهم تدخل البيوت هذول السيدات في
تضارب بالفكر اصلا يعني بدك تساعد السيدات
ويكون هناك سيدات عاملين في هذا القطاع
المشكله اعتقد انه لما يصير في مواجهه ما
بينهم وما بين المجتمع الدولي والمجتمع
الدوليه يربط مساعدات اللي هي اصلا
مساعدات اللي عم تدخل لا افغانستان يربطها
في هذه الامور تؤدي الى نوع من همم
الاقتتال وانا برايي تقوي
الاشخاص اللي
يرغب ان يكون هذا مشكله اصلا فااا المفروض
كان ممكن توضيح همم الاحتياجات اصلا انه
نحن المراه لها ناحيه عمليه وجودها في هذه
المؤسسات هي ليست اضافه للمؤسسه ليست
لانها امراه وانما حتى تكون هذه المساعدات
توصل للسيدات المحتاجين نحتاج ان يكون ان
المراه داخل هجمه ولكن تشعر احيانا بان
الموقف هو اديولوجي عقائدي بالاساس وكانه
هناك تضييق كامل على المراه في كل في كل
مجال في التعليم في العمل مع الاجانب مع
الوظيفه العامه لا تذهب الى الحدائق لا
تذهب الى الفضاءات الثقافيه لا تذهب الى
الفضاءات الرياضيه وكان هناك اهم لحركه
الطالبان الا موضوع المراه هذا هذا اشكاله
صحيح هذا موجود في بعض همم بعض الافراد
وبعد القيادات وبيمثل اكثر الطبيعه عائليه
العشائريه لبعض الاشخاص واللي هم اقليه
ممكن بالمجتمع الافغاني لكنهم اكثريه ما
بين جنود طالبان اللي يعتمدوا عليهم في
القتال في مناطق البعيده عن اا مناطق همم
سيطرهم همم فعلا في بعض هذه الافكار
المنتشره نعم سيد حسن هل هل سنصل في
النهايه الى ان لا مكان للمراه في
افغانستان سوى البيت همم تذهب الى التعليم
الابتدائي فقط لا مكان لها لا في التعليم
الثانوي
بركات ولكن ايضا تمنع من العمل مع منظمات
محليه او دوليه في النهايه وكانه حكم
ببقائها في البيت ليس اكثر
اه ايتين دجاج
في المجتمع في الجانب الثقافي الاقتصادي
وما شابه
طالبان لديها تعريف محدد بشان دور المراه
بشان تفاعل المراه عمل المراه حقوق المراه
السياسيه
غير الحكوميه في التسعينيات من القرن
الماضي والسياسات تقول ان المراه بامكانها
ان تذهب الى الميدان او الى الحقل لك ليس
بامكانها ان تذهب لتستلم راتبها هذا هو
الحد الاقصى الذي تمكنه من تقديمه بالنسبه
للمراه التي كان لديها خلفيه تعليميه التي
كانت تحتاج اليها ليس بالنسبه لي الافغان
مثلا بالنسبه للمراه الطبيبه التي تخدم
اسرتها ولا يسمح لنا لاسرهم بان يتم
علاجهم من قبل والنساء من اسرهم الى جهن
من قبل الرجال
اعتقد ان حتى التعليم الابتدائي
خدمه الرجل والمراه سالفهم سيسمحون للمراه
والرجل ان يعمل نجبا الى جن حتى تخدم
المراه النساء في افغانستان اذن الاسباب
هي واضحه بشان دور المراه
لطالبان
وهناكشن
المرتبط بدور المراه بالمجتمع هي ان اا
تكون امه
لطالب متشدد وان تبقى بالبيت هذا هو
التعريف الواضح بالنسبه للطالبات وهذا ليس
هو تعريف التقليدي بنسبه المجتمع الافغاني
وانا اتحدث كا افغانيه ولدت وترعرعت وعاشت
ولا حياتها في افغانستان هذا ليس هو تعريف
التقليدي للافغان داخل افغانستان وانما
هذا تعريف طالبان بالنسبه للمراه وهم
يفرضون الاشياء التي كانت موجوده في
التسعينيه من القرن الماضي ولا يزالون
ياخذون حتى الان الامور لم تتغير
يشرح لنا اكثر التداعيات لمنع المراه في
افغانستان من العمل في المنظمات المحليه
والدوليه تراجع مداخيل العائلات وربما
ذهاب كثير من العائلات الى مزيد من البؤس
والفقر
ان افغانستان هي احد البلدان الاكثر فقرا
كان هناك مجتمع دولي الولايات المتحده
كان هناك همم تنميه ولكنه استراتيجيه لم
تكن
لتجعل افغانستان تقف على قدميها في
المستقبل
راينا ان النتيجه هي ان افغانيين فقدوا كل
شيء ودخلوا في حقبه جديده
وهذه القرارات
وتداعياتها ستكون همم النقطه التي نوضحها
هو ان هناك املا
ان يتم اا اعاده التفكير في هذه
القرارات ونسمع ونرى ان هناك جهودا يقوم
بها
عدد من القاده اللي اعاده النظر في هذه في
هذا القرار لان النساء والفتيات هم جزء
هام من المجتمع
يمثل نصفه ولا ينبغي ان نمنعهم ونقيدهم
وينبغي ان نجد همم اليه حسب الشريعه
الاسلاميه تسمح لهم بان يستمر في تلقي
تعليمهم
ويقوم بدورهم في المجتمع النقطه الثانيه
هو ان ما تقدمه الحكومه من تدريبات بهذه
القرارات المناعه من التعليم والعمل ان
هذا تاويل للشريعه الاسلاميه همم
هذا هو فهمهم للشريعه الاسلاميه همم
بالرغم من هذه المبررات فهي ليس هو الفهم
الوحيد والتاويل الوحيد هناك تاولات اخرى
للشريعه المتعلقه بتعليم المراه وعمل
المراه
لذلك نحن نامل وان يكون هناك اعاده نظر
وان نشهد في السيف القادم
ان همم يتم رفع هذا
منع
وايجاده همم
جديده مقبوله من ناحيه الشرعيه لكي تستمر
الفتاه في التعلم لان ذلك
الحكومه الحاليه اننا نريد امراه ان تكون
متعلمه
لانها همم تربي اجرنا المستقبليه ولا يمكن
ان نقارنا امراه امنيه بامراه متعلمه
السبب الوحيد الذي يجري الان في النقاش
السياسي والاجتماعي هو ان نحترم الحجاب
نلتزم بالحلال
الحجاب الاسلامي
والحكومه مسؤوله لكي توجد هذه الاليه وتمه
فريق لايجاد بيئه امم يتم فيها تطبيق
الشريعه الاسلاميه ولكن بنفس الوقت ان
يكون هناك دور للمراه الحكومه هي المسؤوله
عن ذلك وينبغي ان تمهد الطريقه والبيئه
لذلك
والناس مستعدون لذلك وليس هناك
نزاع او خلاف حول هذه الفكره
الدكتور بركات همم يعني يؤكد ويعيد على
امكانيه مراجعه القرار امكانيه التراجع
عنه مع انه اشار الى ممكن في الصيف القادم
يعني فتره لا باس بها على ذكر التراجع
وزير التعليم في حكومه
طالبان ال- ال- البعضميه حكومه سلطه الامر
الواقعه يقول حتى لو القوا علينا قنبله
ذريه لن نتراجع
حتى لو القوالب ويقول مستعدون لكل انواع
العقوبات التي يمكن ان نصليها ال ال
المجتمع الدولي
برايك امكانيه التراجع تبقى قائمه
اكيد حتى هو اعتقد يعني
عنده قناعه ان القرار هذا خاطئ لانه اعلن
عنه مع نهايه العام الدراسي هو فعلا يعني
ينوي انه يعلق التعليم كان يعلق من بدايه
العام الدراسي هو استنى لا نهايه العام
الدراسي
فيها عامين دراسيه جمال البلد
والجنوب كلندر ثانيه همم واضح انه ما
عندهش ثقه انه هذا القرار والقرار صحيح
فسيدخل الان في نقاشات نفس الشيء عملوها
عندما علقوا قرار التعليم
فسيدخل الان في نقاشات واعتقد انه في امل
كبير انه يكون هناك مراجعه لهذه القرارات
ليس لان الضغط ياتي من الخارج لانه في ضغط
من الداخل مثل ما سمعت من اخواننا الان
ال- همم الامر همم
حياه او موت للبلد بشكل كامل اقتصاديا لا
يمكن انك تعتمد على 9% من السكان فقد
متعلمين الرجال انهم يمشوا ويعيشوا 40
مليون نسمه بمعنى انت ملك تحكم على
افغانستان انه يكون ضحيه مساعدات دوليه
الى ما لا نهايه وضحيه جيرانه وهو ما عنده
مشكله مع كل الجيران اقتصاديا هو حتى
المساعده الدوليه دكتور بركات الان
المجتمع الدولي يلوح بامكانيه موضوع
المساعده الدوليه الاتحاد الاوروبيه
الدوليه
هو سلاح لكن هم اصلا فقدوا هذا السلاح
عندما علقوا المساعدات بالاصل وعندما
علقوا التحويل المالي الى افغانستان
وعندما علقوا المحادثات تعلقوا كثير امور
ثم وضعهم في زاويه تؤدي الان الى ان
يستخدمه هذه الاوراق للضغط على المجتمع
الدوليه يعني كلام الوزير الالمانيه انه
نحنا سلامنا صندوق الاعمار صندوق الاعمار
معلق ما في صندوق العماره
فهما اصلا لا يتعاملوا معهم التحكومه ولا
مرئي من همم الفلوس من خلال هذه الحكومه
فاعتقد يعني يجب ان يكون هناك حوار حقيقيه
اكبر مع همم مع حركه طالبان اخذين بيع
الاعتبار بعض الانجازات اللي تمت يعني في
انجازات مهمه على اهمها انهاء الحرب وهم
اوقفوا الان حركه الجهاد وهذه بحد ذاتها
يجب ان تؤثر على نظرتهم في التعليم يعني
التعليم خلال الحرب كان مشكله في
التسعينات او يختلف تماما ما بعد الحرب
وبعد انتهاء الجهاز همم
يعني في حاجه الان الاحوال حقيقي ما بين
المجتمع الدولي وحركه الطالبان ولا همم
نضيع الطريق من خلال مناورات همم عقيمه
مثلا
تراجع عن القرار السيد حسن جليل وزير
الخارجيه الباكستاني سر داري قال همم
عدم ربط المساعدات الدوليه بقرارات حكومه
الطالبان الاخيره اكثر من ذلك يقول كل ما
تقلصت المساعدات او تم الربطها
بالتراجع كل ما زاد التضييق على المراه هل
تشاطرين هذا الراي
جزئيا قد اقول
مشروطه من حيث الحصول على الدعم الدوليه
ازازه شروط المجتمع الدولي بشان المساعدات
في نهايه المطاف عندما يتعلق الامر
بالسياسه الخاصه بالمراه الافغانيه القضيه
اعمق من
السعيد الحصول على المساعدات الدوليه سواء
الماديه او غير ماديه لكن في بعض المراحل
اعتقد ان
الافغان ربما قد يغيرون المنظور عندما
يتعلق الامر بسياسات المرتبطه بالمراه
وعلى انهم حتى انهم لا ياباهون حتى
بالاعتراف الدولي لست متاكده اذا كان
المساعده الدوليه او الاعتراف الدولي ربما
قد
يربط باعطاء المراه الحريه التي تستحقها
وكذلك الحقوق الاساسيه هل هذا سيؤدي الى
ربما بعد التراجعات او التنازلات من حيث
السياسات اتفق اتفق من جانب لكن لا اتفق
من جانب الاخر السؤال الاخير للسيد نصره
عقبه يعني لو تكلمت باختصار
هل هناك شعور في افغانستان بان الخوف من
تقلص المساعدات قد يساعد على التراجع على
القرارات التي اشرت اليها اكثر من مره
من القياده العليا في اماره افغانستان
الاسلاميه انهم لا يهتمون بالمساعدات
الدوليه او تعليقها خاصه الشيوخ او القاده
الروحيون
لا ياخذون ذلك بعاد الاعتبار وبالضغوط
الدوليه لكنهم يهتمون
همم
الوزراء
الاقوياء وكذلك موقف الناس اذا هم لا
يهتمون بالضغوط الدوليه بل انهم لا
يستمعون اليها ولديهم رؤيه سلبيه همم
المنظمات
يعني بعد اذنك الدكتور بركات باختصار شديد
سلاح المساعدات ينفع
في الوضع الحالي لا اعتقد يعني سيضر اكثر
لان هو المساعدات اللي بتدخل الان هي
مساعدات انسانيه مساعدات انسانيه يعني فقط
لانقاذ الحياه يعني ما فيش فيها لا دعم
اقتصادي ولا استثمار ولا شيء لكن اللي
ينفع اكثر وهو اللي يمكن اللي ترغب فيه
الحركه
يتم الاعتراف بها يتم الاعتراف بالدوله
وفتح العلاقات والتجاره الاخوه هذه يجب
انها تكون مشروطه بطبيعه الحوكما داخل
البلد نعم ربما لو حصلت على اعتراف قد
تتراجع او قد يساعدها على التراجع انا
باعتقادي سيتم التراجع من نتيجه الضغط
الداخلي يعني لا يوجد حاجه الى المجتمع
الدوليه للضعف ضغط شكرا لك دكتور سلطان
بركات شكرا ايضا لضيفتنا من واشنطن حسنى
جديد ولضيفنا من كابل نصره عقبه كالعاده
ان ننهي بتغريدات حول موضوع هذه الحلقه
البدايه بتغريده للامين العام للامم
المتحده انطونيو تيرس يقول فيها صدمت بشده
من التقارير التي تقييد بان طالبان او
التي تفيد عفوا بان طالبان حضر الدخول
النساء والفتيات الى الجامعات ان الحرمان
من التعليم ينتهي كل المساواه في الحقوق
وسيكون له تاثير مدمر على مستقبل البلاد
احطه طالبان على ضمان المساواه في الحصول
على التعليم للجميع
منظمه التعاون الاسلامي وهي ثاني اكبر
منظمه حكوميه دوليه بعد الامم المتحده
قالت في تغريده لها وصف الامين العام
للمنظمه حضر عمل المراه لدى المنظمات غير
الحكوميه الوطنيه والدوليه بالفعل العقيم
ويضر بمصالح الشعب الافغاني داعيا بشده
سلطات الامر الواقعه الى اعاده النظر في
هذا القرار من اجل الادماج الاجتماعي
للمراه
واضاف في تغريده مكمله لهذه التغريده يقول
بل والاسوء من ذلك انه اي قرار الحذر
سيؤثر تاثيرابيرا على العمليات الانسانيه
وعمليات الاغاثه التي تقوم بها شبكه واسعه
من المنظمات غير الحكوميه الوطنيه
والدوليه لفائده المجتمعات المحليه
الافغانيه الضعيفه وفي السياق ذاته كتب
الدبلوماسيه الامريكيه السابقه
تقول قراره طالبان حضر العمل على النساء
في المنظمات الانسانيه امر مقلق وقاسم
للغايه
انها اهانه اخرى للحقوق الاساسيه للمراه
ولن تؤدي الا الى زياده معاناه الفئات
الاكثر ضعفا في افغانستان حيث تلعب النساء
دورا حاسما في ايصال المساعدات التي تشتد
الحاجه اليها
وننهي بتغريد للدكتور محمد صفر استاذ
مقارنه الاديان والباحث بقضايا الحركات
الاسلاميه يقول فيها طالبان مشكلتها مع
المراه ثقافيه وفكريه من ثقافه القبيله في
البشتون الى ثقافه المدارس الدوبنديه التي
يتربون فيها كلها ثقافات لا تعرف المراه
الا وفقه قولهم ياكور ياقور يعني اما في
البيت هو القمر
بهذا نصل الى نهايه هذه الحلقه موعدنا
يتجدد باذن الله الاسبوع المقبل مع موضوع
جديد
في امان الله
[موسيقى]